la seule façon d'implémenter quelque
chose d'équivalent à une zone
d'exclusion aérienne c'est d'envoyer des
avions de l'Otan dans l'espace aérien
ukrainien et d'abattre des avions russes
et cela pourrait mener à une guerre
totale en Europe le président Biden a
été clair sur le fait que nous n'allons
pas nous engager dans une guerre contre
la Russie
Bertrand Badi bonjour vous êtes
professeur de relation internationale à
Sciences Po auteur des puissances
mondialisées repenser la sécurité
internationale aux éditions Odile Jacob
merci d'être avec nous la Russie
rencontre plus de difficultés que prévu
mais elle avance à un moment donné il
faudra bien négocier quel est son but
d'après vous alors très difficile de
répondre à cette question parce que
c'est le but d'un homme et ce qui se
passe dans la tête de Poutine on l'a dit
beaucoup ces derniers temps personne ne
peut se prévaloir de le savoir ceci
étant on peut raisonnablement penser que
tout ne se passe pas comme le maître du
bien leur aurait souhaité et que on est
contrairement à cette idée qui courait
il y a encore une semaine non pas dans
un contexte de retour d'une guerre à
l'ancienne d'un retour à la guerre
froide mais face à une situation
conflictuelle extrêmement complexe et
inédite c'est-à-dire où l'instrument
militaire doit interagir je dirais avec
l'instrument économique la
mondialisation en fait et le poids la
dynamique la résistance des sociétés et
ça ce sont deux éléments tout à fait
nouveau probablement sous-estimé par
Vladimir Poutine et si Vladimir Poutine
comme nous on le dit généralement n'est
pas très sensible aux arguments
économiques si la rationalité économique
chez lui ne l'emporte pas sur la
rationalité politique ou militaire la
résistance sociale ne peut pas lui
échapper c'est à dire que de toute
manière il faudra qu'il fasse avec et
probablement qu'il revoit ses plans
et en tenant compte de ce paramètre
social donc je pense que l'on est dans
des situations de redéfinition et de
recomposition des objectifs de ce
conflit au jour le jour sachant et ça il
faut pas le perdre de vue que dans tout
conflit quel qu'il soit et quel que soit
sa dureté et sa violence il y a toujours
le pied militaire et le pied
diplomatique et donc le problème de
négociations en ce moment en coulisse
entre Américains et Russes mais on se
parle toujours même entre pires ennemis
et dans les situations les plus
conflictuelles bien sûr il y a même on
peut le dire des scénarios extrêmement
précis sur ce que pourrait être une
sortie de crise le problème
ukrainiens et les Occidentaux par
exemple nous sommes dans une situation à
chaud je dis à chaud parce que dans un
mois dans trois mois la situation sera
différente à chaud il s'agit de faire en
sorte que aucun des
protagonistes ne perdent la face il ne
faut pas oublier que cette est une
guerre de rage menée par Poutine et
quelqu'un qui a cette rage on ne le fait
pas sortir la tête baissée parce que il
risque de déclencher sa ceinture
d'explosif elle va donc il faut trouver
une solution d'équilibre ou personne ne
perd la face on envoie l'architecture
maintenant il y a un problème de volonté
politique et je reviens à mon paramètre
de tout à l'heure d'acceptation par les
opinions publiques et les sociétés et ça
c'est le grand problème dernier élément
ne négligeons pas parce que nous
occidentaux nous chant du Nord on a
tendance à le faire ce qui se passe dans
les pays du Sud ne négligeons pas les
leçons du vote à l'Assemblée générale
des Nations unies il y a
une Afrique qui est un peu sur au bord
de la réinvention de Bandung cette
conférence qui expliquait de la part des
aphro asiatiques que ces affaires là ce
ne sont pas les nôtres on veut régler
d'abord nos problèmes nous chez nous ça
c'est un vent très fort qui souffle au
sud et notamment en Afrique donc c'était
1955 avril 1955 ça a donné naissance aux
non-alignement l'histoire ne se répète
pas mais ceux qui se répètent c'est
effectivement cette exaspération des
pays du Sud par rapport à ses problèmes
du Nord alors que le sud est confronté à
des problèmes énormes qui ne progressent
pas dans leur solution et puis il y a un
autre pivot qui est lâché et au lieu de
se presser de dire que la Chine et
l'Allier de la Russie parce que une
dictature aime une autre dictature il
faut voir que la Chine est plutôt
satisfaite je pense d'un affaiblissement
de la Russie plutôt satisfaite elle peut
continuer à aider discrètement
économiquement la Russie elle le peut
mais justement tout le problème est de
savoir jusqu'à quel point il y a là des
incitations qui peuvent partir de Pékin
du style oui on vous soutient mais etc
ces Pékin qui
d'un certain point de vue le pouvoir
pourquoi parce que affaiblir la Russie
c'est bien affaiblir l'Occident c'est
bien
faire face à l'effondrement du système
économique mondial ou à une guerre de
haute intensité pour la Chine ce n'est
pas bon du tout et enfin c'est propre
avoir la satisfaction d'être le grand
médiateur dans cette affaire pour un
monsieur Silling pings c'est une sorte
de consécration donc c'est un c'est un
sentier qu'il ne faut pas du tout
négliger après l'effondrement de l'URSS
en 1991 néanmoins est-ce que c'était pas
une erreur de maintenir et détendre le
temps au lieu de renégocier un traité de
sécurité internationale oui parce que
l'erreur était double en fait c'est à
dire que en
1991 les Occidentaux ont fait le calcul
2 c'est-à-dire de pôles URSS et enfin
soviétique occidental - 1 l'effondrement
de l'URSS égale 1 on est dans un système
unipolaire que l'on va gouverner et
c'était ça l'idée et rappelez-vous à
l'époque François Mitterrand qui avait
une certaine lucidité sur l'avenir avait
dit mais en maintenant l'OTAN on est en
train de monter la Sainte Alliance c'est
à dire cette alliance de société de pays
qui prétendent partager les mêmes
valeurs et qui prétend ainsi réguler le
monde or un monde mondialisé ne peut
plus être polarisé et l'erreur c'est non
seulement ça c'était la première d'avoir
construit cette alliance qui n'avait pas
de vis-à-vis alors qu'une alliance
allait faite pour contrer un vis-à-vis
donc a été obligé d'inventer un nouvel
ennemi et cette invention de l'ennemi
elle s'est faite peu à peu on allait
chercher la Chine on était chercher la
Russie a créé cette situation
artificielle qui constitue effectivement
une erreur il faut le savoir pour cette
sortie de crise et la sortie de crise
passera nécessairement par une
renégociation du régime de sécurité en
Europe et là le premier de savoir si de
l'OSC et de l'OTAN l'une ou l'autre
l'emportera je pense que au départ
l'idée c'était de confier cette fonction
LOSC qui est raisonnablement le candidat
le plus convaincant à assurer la
nouvelle stabilité du monde
l'organisation de sécurité de
coopération européenne la demande de
volodymeersky le président ukrainien
d'entrée dans l'OTAN et de zone
d'exclusion aériennes est-ce que sont
pas des chiffons rouges pour le
président russe Vladimir Poutine et
est-ce que c'est opportun le message a
été reçu ainsi en tous les cas c'est
très clair il était évident que si on
avait accepté cette proposition du
président
ukrainien de d'établissement d'une zone
de non survol on allait directement à la
confrontation avec la Russie le fait que
l'OTAN est répandu vite et très
clairement
appuyé par la déclaration de blinken que
vous venez de nous montrer montre que le
message a été parfaitement compris et
qu'on est bien dans les pures d'origine
c'est-à-dire on dénonce qui est une
violation évidente du droit
international mais on n'est pas
une partie prenante militaire à cette
guerre merci beaucoup Bertrand Bady
d'être venu et merci pour votre
décryptage de la situation